[Música]
porque aquí en france24 directo américa
continuamos con el cubrimiento especial
que le estamos dando a la novena cumbre
de las américas que se realiza en la
ciudad de los ángeles california allí
justamente está nuestra enviada especial
natalia cabrera natalia que bueno
saludaré nuevamente muy buena mañana de
martes allá madrugando para estas
transmisiones de directo américa le
pregunto entonces que se sabe del
anuncio que tiene previsto hacer hoy la
vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris en
materia migratoria
así es raúl a esta hora está amaneciendo
en la ciudad de los ángeles california
donde tiene lugar este segundo día de la
cumbre de las américas como bien lo
mencionaba la vicepresidenta kamala
harris hará el anuncio hoy durante la
inauguración del foro de los directores
ejecutivos de las empresas de las
américas este es otro de los eventos que
componen la cumbre de las américas y que
organiza la cámara de comercio de eeuu
allí la vicepresidenta kamala harris va
a anunciar
1900 millones de dólares en programas
por parte de 10 empresas que componen y
que participan en este foro como lo son
microsoft meta google entre otras
grandes compañías como coca-cola y pepsi
estas inversiones estarán destinadas en
los países que componen el triángulo
norte de centroamérica que son honduras
guatemala y el salvador y que son los
países que mayor migración generan hacia
el norte del continente
con este plan se espera que la casa
blanca está intentando más
avances en la cumbre de las américas a
pesar de las grandes ausencias de los
principales actores y de los
protagonistas en materia migratoria como
lo son el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador y la presidenta de
honduras xiomara castró quienes dijeron
que no iban a asistir por la decisión
del anfitrión de no invitar a cuba a
venezuela ni a nicaragua por sus
regímenes antidemocráticos y tampoco
asistirá el presidente de guatemala
alejandro giammattei pero éste atribuyó
a problemas de su agenda su inasistencia
entre los anuncios de la vicepresidenta
kamala harris también va a estar un
programa para empoderar empoderamiento
femenino de las mujeres centroamericanas
para acercarlas a la economía digital
este es un programa muy importante para
la vicepresidenta que recordemos es la
primera mujer en llegar a este cargo en
eeuu así es natalia además de este
importante anuncio que va a realizar la
vicepresidenta de eeuu cámara sabes qué
más se espera para la cumbre el día de
hoy
bueno además entonces de la inauguración
de este foro de directores ejecutivos
deseos de las compañías de las américas
también va a continuar el foro de la
sociedad civil estos dos eventos son
hacen parte de la cumbre de las américas
pero son organizados por distintas
organismos este por ejemplo de la
sociedad civil lo organiza la
organización de estados americanos la
oea y por ejemplo un dato importante de
este encuentro es que si bien las
delegaciones de cuba de venezuela y de
nicaragua no van a asistir no fueron
invitadas a la cumbre de las américas si
fueron invitados representantes de la
sociedad civil de estas tres naciones
quienes van a entregar recomendaciones
que esperan se incluyan en la
declaración final que firmarán los jefes
de estado y de gobierno que si asisten a
esta novena cumbre de las américas en
los ángeles y hablemos precisamente de
los mandatarios que si vienen anoche
llegó el presidente de panamá laurentino
cortizo y también el presidente de chile
gabriel boric para hoy se espera que
lleguen los presidentes de colombia y
van que el de ecuador guillermo lasso el
primer ministro de canadá justin crudo y
el día de mañana estará llegando aquí a
la ciudad de los ángeles el presidente
de argentina alberto fernández quien un
dato curioso el presidente de venezuela
desde caracas dijo que será su voz aquí
en el centro de convenciones de la
ciudad de los ángeles